stanford lies
at the heart of silicon valley and when
you think of silicon valley and by
implication stanford
you think of the people who take risks
break boundaries
that's the reason why i think stanford
indeed is a unique
place to understand innovation and
entrepreneurship we have cherry-picked
to be honest the best stanford faculty
we can find
in entrepreneurship and innovation on
one hand you'll have people who will do
more rigorous research like my colleague
huggy rao on the other hand
you'll have folks like perry claibon who
actually
invented the modern snowshoe so we have
that sort of range of folks to bring
together if you will
the rigorous and the relevant or what
the certificate program
and the courses in the certificate
program do
is they inform people about cutting edge
practices
they illuminate principles
underlying innovation and
entrepreneurship but most of all
they inspire people so that you can go
out and innovate
and be an entrepreneur in your own
company or in your own corner of the
world
taught by world renowned faculty from
the graduate school of business
and the school of engineering the
stanford innovation and entrepreneurship
certificate
is a self-paced interactive online
program
where you will gain essential skills and
effective strategies
to generate and implement new ideas
there are many features
that stanford can offer to make the
innovation and entrepreneurship
certificate
suit the needs of your organization your
company's private
branded landing page is the hub of your
program
from the landing page participants can
enter the discussion forum
preview upcoming webinars join the
virtual study hall
connect with other participants read
about the faculty
and access their courses each course is
divided into modules
and contains lectures interactive
assignments and
readings throughout the course the
stanford teaching team will provide
participants
with feedback on select assignments
challenging them to apply their
knowledge
and hone their innovation skills there
are a number of courses to choose from
so you can customize the program to fit
the needs
of your organization so one of our
design principles in the classes
is anywhere you have good internet
access you can take a class
so your employees throughout your
company get to be exposed to them
in a way where they have control over
their time and can pace it
what companies can do is signal to their
high potential individuals hey
you're valuable we need you we want you
one of the things about innovation
is if you want to do better you better
spread it throughout the organization
if you're working even in a large
company and you want to make sure that
your large company has the soul of a
startup
this program is a great place to begin
you